a humble child with a lot of dreams that
is how Jermaine Cole's family remember
the Beloved 14 year old he was stabbed
to death seven times with a machete
after becoming involved in a fight in
South London he managed to stand up with
the help of passers-by but his injuries
were too severe and he died later in
hospital
Marcus Walker was just 16 when he
repeatedly stabbed Jermaine he later
boasted about the killing in the lyrics
of a rap song he wrote this is yet
another case involving the senseless
murder of a young teenager committed
four reasons that no mature adult can
fathom
Jermaine cools was only 14 when you
killed him
he was the youngest victim of fatal
knife crime in London in 2021
Jermaine's father Julius cools says
Walker's sentence is far below what he
deserves I think it's ridiculous and I
think like this simple region gives more
kids to do more killing because
after you told someone at the age of 17
go to prison for 19 years this is
nothing
this is encouraging you like you can do
whatever you want to do and get away
with it he plans to appeal the sentence
we memorize Lord and look at the life of
Jermaine Jermaine was part of a big and
devoted family unable to find any
comfort in the judge's decision they
cherish their memories of a young boy
who was so loved Becky Cottrell Sky News
[Music]